on a fait appel à des invités nous avons
michel fugère qui est trompettiste du
conservatoire de paille nous avons créé
ce soin tests qui est clarinettiste et
saxophoniste joe cuba il avait également
mis mélodie ou intersport t'accuse qui
est flûtiste donc on a réuni ces
personnes-là de qualité pour pouvoir
encadrer les grands ensembles
c'est un moment pour leur donner un peu
d'eux comment on va pratiquer saison de
doc est comme on va faire les nuances
comment va faire la dynamique peut voir
avec la fanfare on a vu avec le base ben
et le big bang ils ont déjà oeuvré dans
avec ce groupe là vendredi 15 à partir
de 18h30 comme ça affecte la fanfare le
l'harmonie la mode chinoise qui a plus
de 60 ans et nous allons continuer avec
le vote du brut qui est un conte aux
caisses du robert avec démissionne cela
me fait très plaisir de les accueillir
parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui apprennent
à faire de la trompette du trombone avec
nos maigres mais c'est notamment
erik guay le directeur chef d'orchestre
et donc ce sera le plaisir gourmand de
les accueillir et également nous avons
le matinik base même que je dirige
l'alizé big ben et on va avoir le
plaisir d'accueillir le vasco les bases
d'un lancer qui nous a contactés pour
cette occasion et nous sommes vraiment
heureux de présenter ce genre de frais
steve mini festive grâce mais c'est
comme un petit bassin que ces groupes
des fanfares des instrumentistes jusqu'à
la fête sur ses atouts sa fait la fête
la fête des cuivres et mais également
des invités sur liste est nous aurons
également john antoine disons que ce
sera un test qui va jouer en solo et ses
fans des caries également il fait
christian florentiny tu va nous
présenter le va faire la paire la part
belle aux saxophones cette année l'année
prochaine peut-être cela le stade de
trop et demi on saute pas cette année
c'est le saxophoniste et ils vont nous
présenter leur répertoire et je crois
qu'effectivement comme vous dites que ce
cas la fête et des cuivres et j'espère
que ça sera tout le monde j'invite toute
la population
grands et petits doivent venir découvrir
c'est justement là on va avoir des
instruments qu'on ne connaît pas comme
le soubassophone voilà les goûts vos
instruments comme le baryton et c'est
donc venez nous découvrir ce vendredi à
18 et autres